[Music]
SuperMario Odyssey displays a clear
understanding of what makes Mario tick
and it's neck and neck for top billing
among its esteemed predecessors it
surprises you with not just inventive
mechanics of which there are many
but with expertly tuned level design in
moments of charismatic wit it is
comfortable and absurdity and wields
this attitude to cut through limitations
of its otherwise straightforward
structure and keep you smiling all along
the way
above all else Odyssey is refined it
generously doles out new worlds to
explore effortlessly cycling from one
charming enemy and unique gameplay idea
to the next its environments are bigger
and some of the most interesting ever
seen in a Mario game and all that extra
space is invaluable as the dense layouts
of challenges and rewards justifies
every building and landmass you
encounter your mission to rescue
Princess Peach from Bowser which
actually takes a surprising turn for a
change is ultimately the hunt for power
moons odyssey's version of the series
star collectibles which are rewarded for
feats big and small like acquiring a
moon can call upon your platforming
skills but it can also entail quirky
activities like answering trivia
questions from a charmingly
simple-minded Sphinx or exploring your
surroundings for buried treasure with a
doting pup who will also play fetch if
you know the trick from boss battles to
tossing your hat onto a peculiar piece
of architecture you can readily stumble
on to new moons even 40 hours in so long
as you make sure to constantly shift
your perspective on the world and engage
with new possibilities as they come into
view
[Music]
you're guided through all of this by
Cappy mario's new sidekick a living hat
that can possess the minds of other
creatures and put you in the driver's
seat the selection of 52 capturable
things spans the likes of lowly Goomba
grunts and flying bullet bills two
unexpected hits like a Christmas tree or
a giant slab of neon meat shoutout to
the Easter Island inspired statues that
wear pink shades to reveal hidden
platforms the opportunities introduced
by possessing others isn't just an easy
source of laughs however but also works
hand-in-hand with odyssey's ever-present
challenges
highlights include a Caterpillar's
ability to stretch around bends like an
accordion and the stout pokeo bird's
beak which can be stuck into walls and
used to fling you to hard-to-reach
places there's usually always something
in sight that you can possess in some
way to exploit its traits there are also
plenty of exceptional set-piece
possessions to look forward to like a
t-rex or the tank you control in new dog
city these emphasize just how impressive
capys ability is in the context of a
Mario game and how Odyssey doesn't want
you to just work for your moons but
enjoy the process from the get-go
[Music]
cappy's usefulness extends beyond his
mind control capability he can be thrown
like a boomerang to retrieve coins or
used as a trampoline to extend the range
of your jumps some of his abilities can
be triggered by a motion controls or
button presses but the few that require
you to flick your controller one way or
the other are unwieldy when playing in
handheld mode it's a blemish albeit a
small one as no critical objectives
require you to manipulate copies
secondary skills by and large these
tricks are easy to use yet difficult to
master in conjunction with Mario's
various flips bounds and hops when used
in harmony Mario's innate athleticism
and cappy's support allow for intricate
and efficient traversal combined with
the games typically unusual tasks and
all the capturable enemies and objects
honestly very quickly becomes a game
that's easy to admire
one of the most interesting facets of it
is it's seamless incorporation of 8-bit
Super Mario Brothers gameplay and
because these sections are 2d it stands
to reason in a game filled with loopy
logic that these occur on the surface of
locations like Lake bottoms or on the
side of skyscrapers despite the stark
difference in presentation these retro
challenges fits smartly not only into
the spaces you're exploring but within
the general flow of gameplay as well
it's also the basis for one of the
game's most elaborate and heartwarming
scenes especially if you're a mario
family
though you no longer wear different
outfits to change his behavior unless
you count bodies he possesses outfits
you can dress up for fun by mixing and
matching a large selection of hats and
suits from Mario's past you can find
costumes inspired by games like Mario
Paint NES open tournament golf and
Yoshi's cookie there are also an array
of real world styles like a bomber
jacket and scuba gear again just for the
fun of seeing Mario cosplay there are
only a handful of chances to use a
costume to your advantage usually to
gain access to a locked room for an easy
moon but that doesn't diminish their
valuable contribution to keeping the
long haul feeling fresh if only in
superficial terms each Kingdom offers
access to two stores where you can pick
up new threads one takes special coins
found in limited supply in each Kingdom
another deviously hidden collectible to
seek out and another that takes generic
coins found throughout the game the
general store unlocks costumes for
purchase based on the number of moons
you've collected the many of them can
also be unlocked immediately if you
possess the right amiibo once you've
finished the main quest recovering about
20% of the game's 800-plus moons the
push towards new outfits is a bonus
giving the amount of undiscovered
opportunities that await but one that
keeps you steeped and powerful nostalgia
as the end game sets lofty moon
collection goals it's interesting to see
how the general store begins to sell
unlimited amounts of moons at a hundred
coins a pop though at least buying moons
doesn't remove them from the world
leaving every challenge intact
this can help expedite the process of
collecting hundreds of new moons or to
get that one or two more you need to
unlock a new costume but relying upon it
isn't efficient or recommended at best
it's helpful in a pinch but it also runs
the risk of undermining odyssey's
top-class level design it's ultimately
difficult to grow bored in the first
place however as a significant number of
new moons and hidden levels open up in
each Kingdom after the credits roll
ensuring that you aren't staring at the
same old locations with the same old set
of eyes
once you reach out to seize more
significant moon demands you're rewarded
with access to small but meaningful new
areas that pack some of the biggest
challenges in the game in short bursts
Odyssey can be challenging throughout
but it's generally forgiving in all
cases in the final stages you're up
against gauntlets that demand consistent
precision dye and you go back to the
beginning though these chapters aren't
as significant as the rest of the game
it's a welcome way to cap off Mario's
quest but there's a fair chance you
still have hundreds of moons left to
find elsewhere Odyssey is sustained
beyond its major milestones not only
through colourful worlds and hidden
challenges but through the sheer joy of
controlling Mario who's never felt more
responsive or dynamic in action even
with everything new that's been
introduced antennas forward-thinking
platformer retains the series classic
handcrafted appeal which is even more
impressive when you realize how densely
packed each kingdom is Mario's latest
outing is big bold and bursting with new
ideas and like breath of the wild is
another instance of Nintendo going above
and beyond to redefine our expectations
it's a shining example of refined
creativity and another crown jewel force
which that is without equal
[Music]
you